la unión europea ha cerrado dos días de
cumbre con la unión africana bajo la
promesa de que esta vez si europa y
áfrica están en la misma sintonía esta
promesa se sustenta en gran parte la
movilización de 150 mil millones de
euros para invertir en infraestructuras
como por ejemplo en transportes también
en conexiones digitales o en sanidad un
dinero que forma parte del conocido como
portal global una iniciativa presentada
recientemente por la comisión europea
que lo que busca es sobre todo hacer
frente a la conocida como ruta de la
seda china un proyecto de inversiones de
este país asiático que lo que intenta
sobre todo es ser más influyente en
varios países pero sobre todo en el
continente africano no es el único tema
que se ha abordado en esta cumbre en que
otro de los temas candentes ha sido la
cuestión de las vacunas de lakovic 19
con el apoyo de la unión europea y de la
oms seis países africanos sudáfrica
egipto kenia túnez nigeria y senegal
podrán crear centros para producir
vacunas de adn mensajeros recordemos
esta tecnología es la que se ha
comprobado ser muchísimo más eficaz en
la lucha contra la cob y 19 y lo que van
a hacer estos centros es tener esta
tecnología que se ha sido transferida
sin embargo a algunos países como por
ejemplo sudáfrica han criticado que a
pesar de que da la bienvenida a este
tipo de iniciativas no es suficiente y
que la solución es levantar las patentes
suspender las patentes de las vacunas la
unión europea siempre lo ha bloqueado
hasta ahora sin embargo la presidenta de
la convención europea a su la van der
leyen ha prometido que en primavera se
va a poder llegar a un acuerdo y para
poder abordar esta cuestión